Ryan what do you think about first of
all Vladimir Putin's comments that the
Russian people and the Ukrainian people
share a culture that there indeed the
same people yeah that was one of the two
comments that really caught my attention
from the Russian president he said it
before look it's it's a deeply
controversial comment and a device one
within Ukraine some people within going
to say in eastern Ukraine for example
the pro-russian rebels would agree with
that many Ukrainians wouldn't and
particularly in the west of the country
and he have really across Ukraine and be
concerned that perhaps the Russian
President and Russia sees themselves as
the sort of big brother amongst
russian-speaking slobs the second
comment that the Russian president made
which i think is very meaningful is when
Charlie was asking about whether Russia
was seeking respect basically Putin said
what we're speaking what we're seeking
is a direct conversation with the United
States I think you know there are a lot
of people out there that say that the
reason why the conflict in Ukraine is
still going on and this larger standoff
between the west and Russia is because
there is no dialogue right now between
Russia and the United States you think
about like conflict resolution when it
comes to Ukraine itself the Germans and
the French have been the brokers and to
be perfectly honest inside the Kremlin
they don't really take the French and
the Germans too seriously Russians like
the sig comes themselves as a superpower
they liked the bipolar world that was
encapsulated by the Soviet Union in the
United States they don't like what they
think is sort of a money mono polar
world now run by the United States and
until the US sits down directly with
Russia to discuss Ukraine and just have
about every other issue in terms of
geopolitics the Russians will probably
at least Vladimir Putin will probably
keep this standoff going but you know
it's pretty clear the United States the
Obama administration doesn't see Russia
as a global superpower they see Russia
as a regional superpower and so guess
what
the conflict is going to continue